hier will einfach jeder hoch der nach
eisenach kommt zur wartburg für viele
deutsche ist mehr als nur irgend eine
burg aus dem elften jahrhundert sie ist
sehenswürdigkeit und nationaler mythos
zugleich
[Musik]
und das liegt vor allem an einem mann
martin luther 1521 vier jahre nachdem er
seine thesen veröffentlicht hatte
übersetzte er hier das neue testament
ins deutsche
eine revolution denn jeder deutsche der
lesen konnte hatte ich jetzt darauf
zugriff
minute war nicht der erste der die bibel
übersetzt hat aber hat sie sehr gut
übersetzt und er hat sie vor allem aus
dem urtext aus dem griechischen
übersetzt und nicht bloß das lateinische
ins deutsche übertragen
eine sonderausstellung zum
reformationsjubiläum erinnert derzeit
auf der wartburg an martin luther mehr
als 300 exponate zeigen wie sich die
sicht auf ihn in den vergangenen 500
jahren immer wieder verändert hat
der nationalheld luther der
kirchenspaltung eine oft umstrittene
historische figur die ausstellung auf
der wartburg zeigt 500 jahre deutsche
geschichte und zwar unter dem
blickwinkel und die deutschen
wie hat die reformation die deutsche
geschichte beeinflusst aber auch wie hat
jede historische pocher ein eigenes
leitbild hervorgebracht immer wieder war
die wartburg schauplatz deutscher
geschichte
viele prächtige seele zeugen davon zb
die kemenate der heiligen elisabeth von
thüringen die im 13 jahrhundert auf der
burg lebte oder der sänger saal wo im
mittelalter angeblich ein legendärer
gesangswettbewerb stattfand und 1817
trafen sich hier rund 500 studenten die
die einheit der damals zersplitterten
deutschen nationen forderten unterhalb
der wartburg liegt stadt eisenach das
lutherhaus wie ihr lebte der reformator
als schüler martin luther begegnet einem
ihm auf schritt und tritt
die georgenkirche in der predigt in
diesem haus oder 1685 eine andere große
persönlichkeit eisenach geboren der
komponist johann sebastian bach das
museum zeigt was luther und bach
gemeinsam haben
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert verbanden
viele ddr-bürger eisenach vor allem mit
ihm dem ddr kult auto wartburg benannt
nach dem wahrzeichen der stadt der 353
jahr wurde mehr als 20 jahre hier gebaut
und hat bis heute fans wie marco müller
der seinen 30 jahre alten wartburg hegt
und pflegt wunsch natürlich auch fährt
der mann braucht bedeutung nicht
tradition der die geschichte von eysel
am starke verbundenheit und heimatgefühl
auch nur weil ich diese stadt mit diesem
auto mit diesem werk aufgewachsen bin
seit mehr als 120 jahren werden eisenach
ununterbrochen autos gebaut
heute hat opel hier eine verbringen
touristen können die waagen in der
automobile welt sehen natürlich auch den
antwort es war ihm auch das besondere
dass die autos die nach selben namen
hatten wie die burg und die unmittelbare
verbindung eisenach wartburg mann stand
das auto stand gleichzeitig eben auch
für die facettenreiche vielfältigkeit
dieser stadt die eine kulturstadt ist
und eine industriestadt das war hier nie
im widerspruch ich sage einfach die
leute haben so einschlug wenn sie den
blut und ein herz für deftiges
abschließen kann man die reise natur mit
den typischen thüringer klößen wie ihrem
haushalt eingestellt werden sie aus zwei
drittel rund einem drittel gekochte
kartoffeln und einem konto in der mitte
des wasser sieben sie so lange bis sie
an die oberfläche kommen
der spitzname der thüringer klöße heißen
hübsches stammt daher weil jede familie
ihr eigenes klos rezept hütet und
deswegen hüte es hübsches und da hat
jede familie eigenarten wie sie noch
diese größe oder diese masse verfeinern
einige hühner kondensmilch darunter
einige eben noch creme freistunde
serviert werden sie mit rouladen und
rotkohl und natürlich einer flasche
rotwein
das ist ja klar in eisenach der
lutherstadt am fuße der wartburg
[Musik]